so this story came out by the way this
is a real story I tweeted this yesterday
I got one minute on the story Sam
bankman freed okay this is from Vice
is trying to find the guy who did this
this is not a joke by the way this is
not Babylon B just so everybody knows
this is real I posted this yesterday and
I posted the link to the article
yesterday Rob I'm gonna send it to you
post a link to the article because this
is not the real article article I just
sent you from Vice this is on Vice okay
just go to the link okay go right there
to Twitter it's right below that tweet
that I send out go a little lower go low
below that you'll see right there click
on that click on that right there this
is vice
Simon was trying to find the guy who did
this okay
Tom and I were talking about this
yesterday Tom's like what he sounds like
O.J Simpson
the Killer's still out there yeah yeah
I'm gonna spend the rest of my life
trying to find out who killed he's gonna
write a book pack I didn't do it but if
I did you know every Golf Course is a
strip club till I find it either this
guy is naive he's dumb he's oblivious he
he he thinks the world is dumb or he's a
psychopath a sociopath but he's one of
those things you decide who this guy is
I don't know how he did it yesterday
Michael said I was talking about this
guy we're on the podcast together with
him shout out to Michael Saylor every
time you listen to this guy your brain
gets muscular head gets bigger because
all your muscles are working but uh yeah
this guy this guy knows exactly what he
did Scott knows exactly what he did and
there's a lot of people that have his
back that are trying to protect them
because all the leaks of texts and
messages and emails and you know
whatsapps and all that if that stuff
leaks I guarantee you a lot of political
leaders are going to be very very
embarrassed by being tied to a guy like
this yeah well it's 38 million dollars
to the DNC and the close send candidates
the super close in candidates it was 38
million that is public and is known
about and so you've got people like
Maxine Waters who are out there they do
not want to be accused of taking money
from the mob that's a political problem
that's as old as the hills you take it
from a developer the developer is really
dirty he gets arrested you run for the
hills because oh I didn't take that
money from my campaign that's the game
being played here anyways we got to find
out who did this yeah we got to find the
person and shout out to his mom for
encouraging him to not take a personal
responses 12 years ago the article blame
is overstated so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetamin it says future
looks bright here future looks bright
here we got them in white we got them in
Black we got them in red our black on
black sold out these are about to sell
out if you haven't ordered one yet we
had a person in Michigan but one then he
bought three than when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks bright
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
[Music]